but oh my God the butt part oh God
[Music]
look okay do I look skinny okay I'm not
wearing a bra so I had to stand like
this
T-Rex
[Applause]
well I'm Maddie Smith and this is answer
the internet would you rather never have
any Buffalo okay topical buffalo sauce
food again
or only be able to masturbate to
pregnant porn Okay so lately I've been
into porn so that's unfortunate for this
question because the Buffalo is gonna
have to go because uh that porn does be
slapping you know what I mean I didn't
really like it lately like within the
last year I've been like oh time to
watch porn like I do it like every day
for the first like it's been like a
routine lately for the first time in my
life and I'm really into it I get
excited to watch it and
um no literally the first time I watched
and liked it I was like oh the men have
a point
I'll let you have that one it's [ __ ]
sick
no I didn't no I don't I don't do crazy
[ __ ] I you know I find what I like I
don't want to give away too much but
girls who look like me okay anyway
you ever watch porn with people who look
like you uh life hack oh okay okay
answer the internet am I bombing or am I
doing okay okay ready you don't have to
read
that like sorry okay we'll edit and post
oh my God I'm just kidding would you
rather get stuck at a red light every
time for the rest of your life or
become a loaf of bread for 24 hours once
a year okay so it's like the risk of
being a loaf of bread is high so I'm
wondering like where am I a loaf of
bread am I in Panera is someone about to
buy me and eat me or am I in a safe am I
in a box like where's the loaf of bread
gonna be because that's what I'm freaked
out by like what happens when someone
takes a bite and then I wake up like is
there a bite out of my [ __ ] titty
because someone ate a loaf of bread that
was me versus the red light there's ways
around that you just
um you just don't drive and that should
be easy enough so I think I'll take the
the red light because you know if I
become a loaf of bread I'm gonna eat
myself all right I'm just like walking
down the street right it's time for your
24 hours of bread you have to be ready
and then what happens if you some you
have someone who like watches you every
time you turn into a loaf of bread but
then you know it's like they start
taking bites because it's like when the
the person you trusted is now and then
you know I'm just saying
and a [ __ ] would I have been betrayed
in my life okay
answer the internet no I'm kidding all
right
um in order for you to live you have to
kill a blind child you guys I'm a
philanthropist in order for you to live
you have to kill a blind child who has
the greatest voice of our generation are
you killing the kid I mean yeah like I
kind of have stuff to do
at the end of the day you're a child
your loss is like way way way less than
what me dying what you don't I'm 31 like
I have my [ __ ] together I'm ready to
live my life I told you guys I'm about
positivity I'm like excited to be here
I'm about to freeze my eggs this guy oh
you're the song of Our Generation okay
well Lena Dunham was the voice of my
generation okay so uh let's just get rid
of him now so that's what I'm saying I'm
killing the kid and you can put that on
video and answer the internet if you
were on an old episode of room Raiders
what would be the most of what would you
be most afraid of being found
um honestly like it's like literally
like I don't know if it's TMI for bar
stool but like sometimes your vibrator
gets a little crusty and I'm avoiding
contact with the camera because that's
horrifying and I know it's going to show
up on my mom's Instagram reels you know
because the moms are on the reels and
that's the most dangerous place to be so
I'm gonna say that the vibrator
otherwise everything is clean as a clam
I'm not trying to pun intended I'm like
stepping on a frame if you had one free
throw and if you make it if you had one
free throw and you've why it's because
it has Sports I'm like
if you had one free throw and if you
make it you get a million dollars but if
you miss you never get to text again
would you shoot it
um yeah because then I can tell everyone
in my life that I can't text like stop
[ __ ] texting me yeah that's when I
want to respond to every text that I get
these days easy and then if you make it
you get a million dollars so this is a
win double win in my situation I would
actually rather take I would miss it on
purpose because I'm like stop texting me
call me if it's that important
oh no I think we're like about to date
but only if you wanted to okay
um would you rather have to tell your
mom every I'm reading like the kid in
second grade who has to go to the
resource room like and everyone's like
come on I'm actually pretty smart okay
would you rather have to tell your mom
everything sexual you've ever done or
have to show her your entire porn
history
um I would probably tell her everything
sexual I've ever done because I've
talked to my mom about some stuff we
joke about like big dicks and stuff like
that and my mom kind of [ __ ] she's
like a hoe she's like been a hoe like
when she left my dad said she was like
out there like finessing her Gluck lock
so I'm gonna say it would be easier for
me to do that then I've told you guys I
only just got into porn so to be sharing
that with your mom is very vulnerable
and I feel like there would be a little
bit of yum yucking you know what I mean
when they're like oh really and you're
just like but if you tell her like
you're gonna fingered at the movie
theaters she'll be like me too because
it's your mom and all moms are hoes
would you rather have your mom send you
a nude or have her send all your friends
a nude
um I think I would have my friends
receive it I would yeah do not show me
that that's horror I told you I was in
porn and [ __ ] like that like I'll do
like step dad born but my real dad keep
in mind go keep him out of my business
okay
what'd you say yeah go ahead you guys
can look at that
I'm related to him I don't want to say
that but you guys can go [ __ ] my dad I
don't care where's my dad I don't want
to see a nude of my mom either that's
TMI would you care
I don't yes I think I would uh even
though I'm getting creepy music now I'm
getting creeped out now I'm like
freaking out about my dad if your dad
and your boyfriend switch bodies and the
only way to get them back to normal was
to bang oh my God that's weird uh the
only way to get them back to normal was
to bang one of them which one would you
[ __ ] wait that's really weird
I don't know but I don't want to [ __ ] my
dad either way physically or emotionally
but I think I would probably I'm a
sapiosexual I just love when a guy has
brains
no I don't have any standards but
um I think I would [ __ ] the mind with
the yeah and just be like let's like
blindfold me blindfold me and put it in
blind for me and put it in like duct
tape me and put it in really because I
don't want my balls on you stop that's
my dad's ball slapping his butt oh man I
was thinking it would just be missionary
you're thinking doggy style oh I was
thinking missionary balls or hitting
like but oh my God the butt part oh God
yeah I don't know they both sound
horrifying but if I could tell my
boyfriend just like blind for me and
just like put it in and just like pump
and dump
like almost so good it's like [ __ ] oh
yeah and then him seeing like you're
buying ah and that's always going to be
in his brain but it's always going to be
mine oh stop that was a horrifying one
I'm driven wet okay
would you rather know the lyrics to
every song ever or get five thousand
dollars to be honest five thousand
dollars could turn my year around and
what's the use of singing if you just
always know every song wouldn't it be
cool to know all the words though it
would be cool it would be cool it would
make karaoke like if you were like like
you know there's always that like a
viral video of a girl like yes oh yeah
and it's so cool it would be great for
me on like a musical show wild and out
I'll start with Eminem I think right
because he's yeah right
so yeah let's do the lyrics oops would
you rather lose a leg or never be able
to have sex again I don't know I think I
would probably lose a leg right sex is
pretty enjoyable can you do a crotch
yeah okay I could be a crutch yeah I
could be a crush I and I can like make
my thing I'm like I'm the girl with the
crutch I need it I need like a stick at
this point so uh yeah I would lose like
because I always look at that like girl
who lost her arm the surfer she was on
People magazine and I'm like okay I need
to lose a limb would you jerk LeBron off
for all of his athletic ability
absolutely I think I would [ __ ] my
career would Skyrocket if I had LeBron's
ability and I just started sneaking it
in I think I would start sneaking it in
with like just like guys like I live in
Queens I would just drop by the b-ball
Court be like you guys want to play and
they're like fine because you know guys
respect women now so yeah yeah sure you
can
and like freak them out would you rather
be the president the pope or whoever is
in charge of North Korea okay so I for
sure don't want to be the president
because that [ __ ] looks like work and
everyone is like making memes of him
every day that would be my worst waking
nightmare if everyone was just meming me
up and you had the number one job in our
country and you're also 81 you should be
in Florida I do not want to be in charge
of North Korea that sounds like a lot of
micromanaging I would [ __ ] and uh you
know what I mean there's like so much
like right and you're just like always
watching what they do like okay like you
have issues get on Lexapro but I would
be the pope because that looks [ __ ]
chill as hell all you have to do is like
splash water at people like go out to
the balcony what's up if I was a pope
[ __ ] you can use condoms you go to right
Dogs Go to Heaven gays go to heaven you
can go see Bros
okay if you could be a master at one of
the four bases of sex but you'd have to
below be below average at every other
base which one would you choose I have a
pretty good head game and I'm like
facing away from the camera again but I
actually joke about in my stand-up so
it's not like it's like a new thing that
I'm uncomfortable talking about but uh
so I've been um and it's awesome because
like having a dude nut in your mouth and
you're like [ __ ] yeah dude
don't text me back again [ __ ]
you just nutted in my mouth I will
always have power over you and that is
better than than Heaven because at the
end of the day if you're like mid at
like sex stuff you still got a [ __ ] you
know what I mean like that [ __ ] still is
there oh if I can't ride you I still got
a [ __ ] but having a good head game will
like change how a man views you you will
change a man's bad at sex but just let
me do whatever I want yeah yeah good
we're as good at head it's like whoa
It's a powerful thing that's something
that's like you have and you don't have
exactly exactly hand job man I'm good
that's a random skill that I do not need
I think on both sides guys and girls
we're both going down they're like
uh we're all like performing like we're
[ __ ] [ __ ] set Magic City in Atlanta
but no we're in our studio apartment uh
that smells like beans and we're just
trying to get each other off so everyone
chill out everyone needs to chill out
sex is getting weird and I'm gonna be
honest
I'm gonna be honest
I think I've said too much today should
I throw this yes okay oh that's it okay
thank you for watching answer the
internet please subscribe to the channel
comment below on other celebrities you'd
like to see and make sure you hit the
Bell to get notifications when new
episodes come out